[Music]
[Music]
this is it thank you my wife and I was
supposed to be in Paris for her 40th
birthday as we speak one of the things I
was most looking forward to he was
sitting in a bistro and eating a bowl of
French onion soup this is a real
challenge for me because I love French
onion soup with all my heart but the
point of French onion soup it's meat
stock and you're available some of the
things you have at a French bistro most
of the classic recipes you have are in
somewhere combined with the other
elements of how a bistro runs and the
French onion soup was the best way of
using the fantastic stock that you made
from the leftover chicken bones beef
ribs that's why it tasted like let's do
a lot of thinking about how to make a
really good reach clear dark stock to
make the root for your onion soup so
we're going to start this one with a veg
stock when you cook garlic down it stops
being garlic in it comes really rich a
new Bobby
we've got our onions I only got three a
dead bit of spring onion two floppy
dirty parsnips a leek that's really
losing its erection a celery I've got
one carrot this one's okay I've got
carrots celery and I've got turn it
randomly yeah grab you turn it mushrooms
mushrooms are a good umami flavor grab a
peeler it's a much unloved vegetable
isn't it Nat Turner it really is so I've
saved the carrot peelings you don't save
the turnip feelings they won't be so
good I'm gonna peel the parsnips but not
save the parsnip earrings chunk the
carrots up so all these years I've been
eating French onion soup and of course
it tastes so good
I've been eating it with a meat stove
course I have both Frances saw a country
when you tell them that you're a
vegetarian and they say ah I'll bring
you some chicken I don't eat chicken
I'll bring some fish no sorry I tends to
end up eating a lot of cheese and they
go there and bread which you know it
could be worse chunks going your
roasting tray this is the spot I've got
too many shots leave the skin on and put
them in the roasting tray tops and tails
off all your onions and the peel into
the stock coffee so a lot of stuff that
you wouldn't normally eat not looking
that appetizing
or acidic garlic bottom into your
roasting tray chunks of celery into the
roasting tray with the leaf or dried up
the leaves are going to go into the
stock pot and the root part into your
roasting tray I've got the top the
mushrooms with the roasting tray a pinch
of time into the roasting tip oh I just
put in the wrong one
luckily it landed in suea and onions
peeled okay you got some more work
Marmite is a pop is obviously one of
those things that people have been
stockpiling got a shot a dark soy sauce
face of them are my into the roasting
tin that will help tablespoon full of
fresh mustard in there as well then I'm
gonna sprinkle on some mustard pattern
vegetable booyah yes so it keeps
teaspoonful of that sprinkled over the
top pepper and salt
give them a big glug of oil mix all that
stuff through oh man I haven't been this
messy since I changed my camera person's
nappies last
put it into a hot oven about 180 maybe
check it in 10 minutes struggle it about
and then give it another 10 minutes well
there's all sorts of interesting things
happening in here that's absolutely
perfect vegetables into the stock pot
we're gonna pour a short of boiling
water into the bottom of this and then
use the spoon to scrape every last bit
of the black gunge off and dissolve it
into the water beautiful it is so
valuable the gun just value but why is
that it's concentrated flavor in there
and it's all the burnt caramelized
sugars and flavorings from the outside
of the vegetables add a vegetable sauce
the vegetable juices of leave Ted it's a
beautiful beautiful thing so you pour
all of that into your stockpot how clean
should be the rest things may be looking
because there's quite a lot of this
stuff on this look perfectly clean
you're fired from the kitchen put in
that top up the stock with cold water
until the vegetables are covered you
want this to almost bubble almost simmer
but just below simmer for probably about
an hour but a large dollop of butter at
the top of your pan grab your piece of
freeze proof fold it in half
vomiting forces in eighths and 60s
know once again half for sir 816 like
that
nope you've got like the nose of the
paper plate at one in did I get
technically okay use the point to
measure the radius of the pan like that
cuts off have a circumference and they
snip off the tip now I bet and it was so
easy as well
the idea of this stage is just to get
them soft and broken down so I'm
stopping a tiny bit a brand okay this is
the exciting bit you need a bit of paper
that's called a cartouche put it on top
of the onions and then put the lid back
on leave them on the low light if you go
back every sort of five minutes or so
give them a stir
lift the paper would give them a stir
paper back top back on so let's put it
through a sieve match it with the back
of the spoon a little bit but a great
color that's going to need salt you
could use soy instead of salt the whole
of this process now is just tasting
testing tasting testing I'm gonna hit
one it for the touch of Worcester sauce
because that never goes wrong some msg
some ajinomoto Japanese flavor powder
but this stuff is the extract of seaweed
Oh what so like George's marvellous
medicine this isn't it exactly what can
we put in that most things benefit from
a very small shot of vinegar or lemon
juice as well turn the heat up a little
bit more this time from that liquid or
the heat quite low and put in a level
tablespoon full of flour
this will help the whole soup to thick
and really beautifully do you have any
brandy it's at my cupboard burn as long
as I can remember put in a fair-sized
short breaks the blossom stop it doing
so by pouring in some of the vegetable
stock then you stir it to all combines
[Laughter]
yes that's good it's got a real depth
already a pinch of dried thyme into it
I'm putting a sprig of fresh thyme in
mind you've got more stop pouring it all
to serve your soup in it needs to be
ovenproof now have you ever seen yeah
old better suited to onion soup and no
but I think it's ever been used before
that's a crew toxic on the surface can
you make a crouton out of a bagel
that's the only bready product that
we've got there
cut it into three sections fingers on
one of the most highly reported domestic
accidents in Manhattan is Babel hand I'm
going to use a slice of bread Chuck that
in the toaster for a minute or so great
yourself a nice big mound of Greer make
sure there's plenty of onion in there I
have to say this smells like the real
deal
crouton off the top of your soup then
put a load of cheese on top of that get
a grill if you were real prime do you do
this blow lamp it's on yeah yeah that is
right this is sizzling I can see it
sizzling I just block just blowing it
yeah it's superb would you be able to
tell that it was a vegetarian version is
it lacking a depth no I can't tell you
how pleased I am with this that would
never afford you could do a veggie
version that is the real thing
this to me is just fantastic it's had
taken me to Paris where I should have
been this week this is it Tim thank you